Also seit Husten, ich habe Husten und auch Luftnot eigentlich schon seit sechs Wochen, aber seit einer Woche ist das sehr viel schlimmer geworden.
Ich verstehe. Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser? Was denken Sie?
Ja, also ich kann mich nicht mehr groß belasten. Treppen steigen oder auf der Straße eine Steigung gehen, das fällt mir sehr schwer.
Da muss ich oft anhalten, weil ich keine Luft bekomme, weil ich Husten habe. Ja, das ist so das.
Okay, ich verstehe. Haben Sie Schmerzen in Brust? Nein, direkt Schmerzen habe ich eigentlich nicht in der Brust.
Okay, haben Sie Herzprobleme? Ja, Herzprobleme. Bisher sind die bei mir nicht bekannt, Herzprobleme. Kann ich nicht sagen.
Alles klar. Gibt es bestimmte, etwas diese Beschwerden, Linder oder Verstärk?
Also Verstärken tut das Anstrengung. Aber wenn ich mich ruhig verhalte, dann geht es, aber da habe ich auch Husten.
Also das ist schon so. Haben Sie Auswurf? Ja, habe ich auch. Teilweise viel Auswurf, besonders morgens.
Wie sieht die Ehe aus, Wurf aus? Gelblich bräunlich.
Haben Sie Fieber? Ja, meine Frau hat gesagt, ich fühle mich warm an, da habe ich gestern Abend gemessen, da hatte ich 38,6.
38? Haben Sie Schüttelfrost oder Nachschweiß? Also Schüttelfrost nicht, aber ich habe in den letzten Nächten doch ziemlich stark geschwitzt.
Haben Sie Füyer, äh, ein Läbeischwärde? Also ich habe häufiger, besonders im Winter, habe ich häufiger starken Husten und Bronchitis und da habe ich dann auch häufiger Antibiotika bekommen.
Im letzten Winter, zweimal, ja im letzten Winter.
Alles klar. Haben Sie weitere Beschwerden? Also wie gesagt hauptsächlich dieser Husten und diese Luftnot. Das ist das Schlimmste von allem.
Okay, alles klar. Ich möchte Ihnen ein paar Fragen zur allgemeinen Gesundheitsstelle. Haben Sie bemerkt in nächster Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Also abgenommen habe ich nicht viel, nein, zugenommen auch nicht. Also ich glaube, ich habe mein Gewicht weitgehend gehalten.
Okay. Hattest Sie Ihr Appetit verandert?
Ja, jetzt in den letzten Tagen, seitdem ich diese Luftnot so habe, da habe ich keinen Appetit. Da habe ich nicht gut gegessen.
Meine Frau hat mir mal gesagt, ich muss auf alle Fälle was trinken. Das habe ich gemacht, aber ich hatte keinen guten Appetit.
Okay. Haben Sie Schluppe, Schweiter?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise kann ich ganz gut schlafen, aber die letzten Wochen, wo ich eben diese Luftnot hatte und den Husten verstärkt, da muss ich auch nachts häufiger husten, da war der Schlaf nicht so gut.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Stuhlgang ist in Ordnung, ob ich jeden Tag Wasser lassen. Ich muss nachts einmal, manchmal zweimal auf Toilette Wasser lassen, aber nach normalerweise kann ich wieder gut einschlafen.
Nur die letzten Tage nicht so, wegen dem Husten oder der Luftnot.
Okay. Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe seit fünf Jahren muss ich Tabletten nehmen gegen Zucker.
Seit fünf Jahren ist das ja. Und dann nehme ich auch noch Tabletten ein gegen Gicht. Ich habe zweimal Gichtanfälle gehabt und da sagt der Hausarzt die Hansore.
Hansore ist zu hoch, die muss gesenkt werden. Dann nehme ich auch ein Medikament ein.
Erinnieren Sie welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Ja, ich habe so ein Zettel da. Auf der Zucker nehme ich das heißt mit Formin.
Welche Dosierung und wie viel nehmen Sie?
Also da steht 850 dahinter und da nehme ich zwei am Tag, eine Tablette morgens und eine abends.
800?
850.
Okay. Sie sagen, ich habe zweimal Gichtanfälle.
Ja.
Gibt es noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Nein.
Seit fünf Jahren.
Also der Hausarzt sagte, ich würde jetzt langsam eine chronische Brontitis bekommen, weil das hier jetzt so häufig mit dem Husten und mit dem Dingsdamm muss ich dem nicht zum Lungenfacharzt.
Er hatte mir eine Überweisung geschrieben, aber der Termin ist erst in fünf Wochen.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Wann war Gichtanfälle?
Vor drei Jahren und vier Jahren. Seitdem nehme ich auch eben die Tablette ein.
Ich verstehe. Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, als Kind wurde ich operiert an einem Leistenbruch.
Leistenbruch?
Ja, und im Alter von 45 Jahren hatte ich eine Meniscus-Operation.
Links am linken Knie, da wurde eine Spiegelung gemacht und da wurde der Meniscus operiert.
Ja, das waren meine Operationen.
Okay. War das schon mal, ist das dann im Krankenhaus?
Ja, bei den Operationen.
Während der Operation war ich im Krankenhaus.
Sonst war ich noch nicht im Krankenhaus.
Sind Sie vorstandig?
Ja, mein Hausarzt achtet darauf.
Er sagt mir immer, welche Impfungen notwendig sind jetzt.
Ich glaube, da bin ich, ich bekomme demnächst wieder eine Grippeimpfung und eine Impfung gegen Corona.
Corona, okay.
Alles klar.
Waren Sie schon mal in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Im Ausland. Ich war vor einem halben Jahr in Italien, für ungefähr zehn Tage.
Aber sonst war ich in letzter Zeit nicht im Ausland.
Okay, alles klar.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, mit Formin, und dann das Mittel gegen die Gicht.
Allopurinol heißt das.
Ja, Allopurinol.
Wissen Sie welche Dosierung?
Dahinter steht 300.
Und da nehme ich eine Tablette.
Morgens.
Nehmen Sie bei Bedarf oder flänzische Heilung?
Nein, sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergen oder Unfallschrecklichkeit?
Ist mir nicht bekannt.
Super.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, das ist mein Problem. Mein Problem ist das Rauchen.
Ich rauche ungefähr eine Schachtel Zigaretten pro Tag und das aber schon 40 Jahre.
40.
Und bis wehre es?
Rauchen aufgehören?
Ja, habe ich schon probiert.
Ich habe schon so ein Programm mitgemacht von der Krankenkasse.
Und habe schon mit Raucher, Kaukummi und mit Pflaster.
Aber das hat alles nichts geholfen.
Ich muss mir das noch mal überlegen.
Jetzt muss ich erst mal demnächst zum Lungenfacharzt gehen.
Und mal schauen.
Das ist mein Problem, das Rauchen. Meine Frau sagt das auch.
Ich freue mich zu hören.
Wenn Sie möchten, dann...
unser Gespräch bieten eine Programme in Krankenhaus aus.
Okay.
Das können wir ja dann sehen.
Hauptsache, ich kriege jetzt demnächst besser Luft wieder.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke abends schon mal so zwei Flaschen Bier.
Zwei Flaschen Bier.
Viel, viel Jahre trinken Sie?
Auch, auch so 40 Jahre.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefragen.
Bitte nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein. Nein.
Okay.
Gibt es in bestimmten Erkrankungen Ihre Familie?
Ja.
Mein Vater, der ist im Alter, da war er 76,
Jahre alt ist er an Lungenkrebs gestorben.
Tut's mir leid?
Ja, die Mutter, die lebt noch.
Die ist 92 Jahre alt.
92?
Ja, die hatte vor 20 Jahren Hautkrebs,
schwarzen Hautkrebs,
wurde operiert.
Aber das ist gut geworden.
Und sie hat starke Knochenbrüchigkeit.
Ihre Knochen brechen schnell, wenn sie fällt,
wenn sie stürzt, hat sie sehr oft Knochenbrüche.
Okay.
Dann habe ich noch eine Schwester.
Eine Schwester?
Ja.
Ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Der Bruder hat auch Zucker.
Der Bruder hat hohe Cholesterinwerte.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet,
wohne mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Wir haben zwei Kinder.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, die sind 35 Jahre alt
und 37 Jahre alt, die sind gesund.
Und 37?
Was machen Sie in der Beruf?
Inzwischen bin ich Rentner.
Seit einem Jahr habe ich als Schweißer gearbeitet.
Schweißer?
Ja, das ist auch nicht so ganz gesund.
Man atmet sehr viel Dämpfe ein.
Es war ein anstrengender Beruf.
Ich verstehe.
Fühlen Sie sich manchmal Stress?
Nicht mehr, inzwischen nicht mehr.
Die Arbeit war teilweise sehr anstrengend.
Aber seitdem ich jetzt in Ruhe stand bin,
bin ich Rentner, ist das gut.
Träubeln Sie regelmäßig Support?
Nein.
Früher habe ich als junger Mann Fußball gespielt.
Aber das schon lange nicht mehr.
Das waren alle meine Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Herr Dingedissen?
Ja, Hauptsache, mir wird bald von Ihnen geholfen,
dass ich besser Luft bekomme
und weniger husten muss.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Sie sind gut handeln
und so erscheint körperliche Untersuchungen
und Laborparameter überprüfen.
Dann können Sie weitere Schritte informieren.
Gut, das können wir so machen.
Danke.
Dann haben Sie etwas Zeit, sich vorzubereiten.
Übersetzen Sie die Patientenbegriffe,
möglichst in Fachbegriffe.
Wenn Kollegen Fragen haben,
bitte stellen.
Wenn Ergänzungen notwendig sind,
können wir das jetzt gerne machen.
Ergänzungen?
Beruflich, was machen Sie?
Ich habe Akustik nicht verstanden.
Können Sie das noch einmal wiederholen?
Ja, beruflich.
Ich bin Schweißer.
Der Schweißer, der Schweißt Metalle zusammen.
Wenn Metall verbunden wird,
dann ist der Schweißer mit einem Schweißgerät.
Das nennt sich Schweißer.
Metallbau zum Beispiel.
Ja, zum Beispiel.
Ich würde mal sagen, die entscheidenden Informationen,
die Redflex, sind hier bei,
ich nenne jetzt die allgemeinen Bezeichnungen,
Husten, Luftnot, seit sechs Wochen,
mit Verschlimmerung seit einer Woche.
Husten ist gelblich,
bräunlich, vielleicht auch manchmal etwas rötlich.
Keine
wesentliche Gewichtsabnahme.
Patient ist deutlich
eingeschränkt in seiner Leistungsfähigkeit.
Keine
Udeme.
Ein Zucker seit fünf Jahren bekannt.
Eine
höhte Harnsäure mit
Gichtanfällen seit ungefähr drei Jahren.
Eine deutliche
Nikotinkonsum
regelmäßig seit 40 Jahren.
Ja, das sind so die
wesentlichen Punkte,
die man vielleicht,
in der Vorstellung,
benennen soll.
Sie können sich ja dann melden,
wenn sie so weit sind.
Dann sagen sie mir grad Bescheid.
Ich bin bereit.
Okay, okay, dann können wir gerne anfangen.
Sehr geehrter Herr Oberarzt,
ich möchte Ihnen heute unseren neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Ich möchte Ihnen heute unseren neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Die an amnächtigen Angaben deuten am ersten auf.
Asthma bronchiali hin.
Als differential Diagnose
kommen die folgenden Betra
Bronch-Lungencrapes
und
ich möchte ein bisschen
Patienten ersehlen.
Okay, kurz auf die
Begrüßung.
Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt,
haben Sie etwas Zeit für mich?
Ich möchte Ihnen ein Patient vorstellen.
Ja, habe ich.
Vielleicht sagen Sie dann erst mal, um wen es sich handelt.
Herr Dingerdissen ist ein 64-Jähriger Patient.
So und so groß
und so und so schwer.
Herr Oberarzt, das ist wie der Patient heißt.
Okay, alles klar.
Herr Dingerdissen ist
64-Jährige Patientin.
Wegen
die sich und
seit 6 Wochen
das ist neu.
Und
die Plexi
uns vorstellte.
Der Patient berichtet,
dass
Schupputung
gebliegt
und
diese Husten im Winter
und in den Naher
sind wir sehr schlimm.
Es handelt sich um
der 64-Jährigen Patientin, der seit 6 Wochen
über Dispnö
und Tussis.
Husten klagt
mit einer Ex-Azibation
seit einer Woche.
Der Patient hat gesagt,
dass die Plexi-Azibation
noch schlechter geworden ist.
Das Secret
des Ex-Pecturants
wird als gelb- und gelblich- und bräunlich beschrieben.
Bräunlich ist vielleicht auch noch eine wichtige Information.
Gelblich und bräunlich.
Es bestehen
febrile Temperaturen von 38,5 oder 6 Grad.
Das sind wichtige Informationen.
Danke, bitte fahren Sie fort.
Die Fragen nach
Herzproblemen
wurden verneint.
Der Patient erzählt,
dass vor 2 Jahren
im Winter
chronische Bronschitis
hat.
Antibiotika
genomen
und die Anamnese
war bis auf
in Zomni
in Appätenz
unanfällig.
Vorerkrankung
erhielt
5 Jahre Diabetes
mit Luthus.
Er nimmt
mit Formen
650 Milligramm
850 Milligramm
abends
morgens
und abends
vor 3 Jahren
Diabetes-Urika
dagegen alle Prünen
300 Milligramm abends
Da
Patientin berichtet
...
Als Kind war
Herrni-Operationen
...
Leistenbruch ist Herrnia Inguinalis.
Herrnia Inguinalis
oder Inguinal-Hernia.
Herrnia Inguinal-Hernia-Operationen
und
vor 4 oder 5 Jahren
Link meniscus operiert wurden.
Ja, das war aber im Alter von 45 Jahren.
Also als der Patient 45 Jahre alt war.
Ja, fünf Jahre.
Da wurde eine meniscus OP durchgeführt.
Wissen Sie die Technik, wodurch war es eine offene OP?
Artroskopie.
Artroskopische meniscus OP oder meniskel.
Ja, okay.
Gut.
Ja.
Die Menisces war unauffällig.
Er ist vollständig geimpft und gegen Grippe und kommt neu sein.
Der Patientenrau seit 40 Jahren anschahten pro Tag und er trinkt seit 40 Jahren am Abend
zwei Fleischerbeer.
Okay, sagen Sie ruhig.
Es besteht ein Nikotin-Abosus von 40 Packages.
Also Paket.
40 pro Tag, eine Schachtel.
Ein Paket 40 Packages.
Ja, und das ist schon ein Nikotin-Abosus, kann man sagen.
Man kann auch allgemein sagen Nikotin-Konsum 40 Packages, aber das sollte man ruhig,
sollten Sie betonen.
Weil das ist schon wichtig auch für die Erkrankung.
Gut.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint und Familienanamnese ergab.
Die Mutter leidet an Ostoperöse und Melanoma.
Ja.
Wann war das Melanom?
Wann war das mal die Melanom?
40 Jahre.
Vor 20 Jahren.
Wie alt ist die Mutter, wissen Sie das?
92 Jahre.
Sehr gut, ja.
Und der Vater?
76 Jahre alt.
Ja.
Lebt der Vater noch?
Leider nicht.
Der Vater hat an Lungenkarzenum gestorben.
Ja, oder Sie können auch sagen ein Lungenkarzenum oder vielleicht Brontialkarzenum.
Wir wissen es nicht genau.
Brontial oder pulmonal, CA, ja, Karzenum, ja, ist ja verstorben.
Gibt es Geschwister?
Ja.
Schwister leidet an Asmabronchiale.
Brot leidet an Diabetes mellitus und Hypercholesternemie.
Gut, ja, okay.
Ja.
Der Patient ist verheiratet und hat zwei Gesunde Kinder.
Er ist ...
Schweißig.
Rentner, aber er hat ...
hat als Schweißer Bereich gearbeitet.
Als Schweißer, das ist der Beruf Schweißer, Schweißen.
Ist so ähnlich wie Schweißschwitzen, aber Schweißen ist diese Technik im Metallbau.
Wenn Metalle aneinander fixiert werden, ja,
schauen Sie das vielleicht noch einmal nach im Wörterbuch oder im Internet, Schweißen.
Ja, alles gut.
Ja, danke. Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Verdachtdiagnose ist Asmabronchiale oder COPD.
Ja.
Aber ich denke mehr COPD, weil ...
der Patient gibt viele Risikofaktoren.
Ja.
Nikotun Abosus und ...
Pronische Bronschitis und Alta.
Alta, ja, okay.
Und sehr wichtig ist ...
Schweißer Bereich.
Dann ...
diese Beruferursachen ...
Lungenerkrankungen.
Ja, okay.
Ja.
Also, danke. Ich denke, erst mal das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht.
Ja, danke.
Sie haben auch die ganz überwiegend die wesentlichen Begriffe übersetzt in die Fachsprache.
Denken Sie nur daran, der Leistenbruch. Da haben Sie gesagt, hernia, leiste.
Sagen Sie da ruhig inguinal hernia oder hernia inguinalis.
Ja, das ist die, der Leistenbruch.
Und die Operation ist dann die herniotomy.
Herniotomy.
Ja.
Die ...
Ich teile den Verdacht.
Ich bin mit einem Asthma-Bronchale, wer ich nicht so ganz einverstanden.
Ich glaube eher, der Patient hat eine COPD.
Wahrscheinlich eine COPD.
Eventuell vielleicht sogar ein Bronchalkarzinom einbeginnendes.
Das wissen wir noch nicht.
Aber bestimmt eine ex-Azubierte COPD.
Dafür spricht diese Dispnoe.
Der Auswurf, die Belastungsdispleuhe
und auch die Leistungseinschränkung, das Alter.
Die Nikotinanamnese, langjähriger Nikotinabusus
und auch natürlich der Beruf als Schweißer
kann pneumologische Erkrankungen machen.
Das kann auch ein Asthma machen.
Es gibt so einen Schweißer,
aber ich glaube, in diesem Falle
würde ich eher an eine COPD denken.
Es ist aber nicht entscheidend,
eine richtige Diagnose zu stellen,
sondern sie sollen in die richtige Richtung denken.
Aber ich denke, das haben sie gut gemacht.
Ein kleiner Kritikpunkt.
Sie wollten bei ihrer ersten Vorstellung gleich
im Anfang eine Verdachtstiagnose sagen.
Ich würde anfangen und sagen,
ich möchte Ihnen Herrn Dinger-Dissen vorstellen.
Ein 64-jähriger Patient, geboren 12. Januar 1961.
1,81 m groß, 82 kg schwer.
Herr Dinger-Dissen berichtet
seit sechs Wochen über eine Öffnungsdauer.
Sie hat sich in der Zeit von 18 Jahren
eine Erkrankung von 1,8 m im Jahr gebeten.
über eine Dispnö, besonders Belastungsdispnö,
verbunden mit Tussis,
mit einer Verschlimmerung oder Ex-Azibation
seit einer Woche.
Dann können Sie aufrichten, wie das Expektoranz aussieht.
Gelblich, bräunlich, vielleicht, leicht rötlich.
Dass er
fibrile Temperaturen hat
von 38, 35, 36.
Das haben Sie alles berichtet.
Am Ende würde ich dann wahrscheinlich fragt der Oberarzt,
die Oberärztin, was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Sie können vielleicht am Ende sagen,
ich habe folgende Verdachtdiagnose bei den Patienten
mit einer Differenzialdiagnose.
Das ist eigentlich ausreichend.
Ich würde nicht gleich zu Anfang die Verdachtdiagnose sagen.
Sie haben ein bisschen
Neugierig-Ordarchiträt.
Meine Prüfungtermine
nach einem Monat.
Ja, okay.
Ja, gut. Aber ich habe ein gutes Gefühl.
Und lassen Sie sich nicht,
bleiben Sie ruhig, bleiben Sie konzentriert.
Das ist nicht so einfach,
aber immer wieder üben.
Ja, gut. Ja, danke.
Ich würde
möchte Folgendes vorschlagen.
In einer Woche am Donnerstag, da kann ich nicht.
Aber am Freitag kann ich.
Dass Sie bitte das mitteilen,
kommunizieren, wenn das geht,
dass ich am Freitagabend um 18 Uhr
dann mit Ihnen trainieren.
Ist das in Ordnung?
Dankeschön.
17. Oktober oder 14.
24. Ok, alles klar.
Also nicht morgen, sondern in einer Woche.
Ja, ich notiere.
Gut. Dann wünsche ich Ihnen
einen schönen Abend alle.
Und Ihnen noch eine gute Vorbereitung
und alles Gute bis nächste Woche. Tschüss.
Alles Gute. Tschüss. Dankeschön.